your meth is good Jesse as good as mine
silly pea [ __ ] I can get away with
saying meth but you use the B word and
now I got a yellow dollar bill sign but
it's only one B word out of the whole
video can't be that bad for kids do you
think YouTube is gonna think about that
dogs I was talking to a dog do you think
YouTube's gonna go okay well now that
I've explained it and it's here for
someone to look at and understand you
know if they send a manual reviewer you
know they'll understand me I just want
you to know that after we edit this
video if we get a yellow dollar bill
sign I'm blaming you
that sounds fair all right we're gonna
watch from this channel that I've seen a
lot of my own time called screen crush
if you guys like great breakdowns Easter
Egg videos and certain video essays you
guys will love screen crush there's a
link in the description box for this
channel linked in the pin comment we're
gonna watch today Breaking Bad the most
crucial episode I've been on a better
call Saul high as of late so I thought
this would be a great time specifically
for me to watch let's do this are you
asking me to come work for you you're
brilliant you you you got a ton of
experience pity pity ah freakin bad is
famously a show about cheese but when
exactly did that change take place
women Walter White go from this veggie
bacon
watching our cholesterol to this I am
the one who knocks the crux of the
entire show is the fifth episode of
season one grey matter
in the previous episode this guest sees
money and swears off cooking meth
because he just killed a guy get the
hell off my property
but later he invents a new identity for
himself
Rosenberg the gray matter shows Walt's
transition between these two states
without this episode the show could have
fallen apart so how did this happen well
there are three sequences in this
episode centering on Wall Street fusil
to accept
therapy I called them the offer the
options and the choice these three
sequences carefully show Walt's
decision-making process and provide a
roadmap to his soul the offer happens in
Elliott Schwartz was birthday party
though they never say it specifically
I assume this is Elliott's 50th birthday
given that everyone is making such a
fuss and Walt just turned 50 but
Elliott's party is the monthly works
traveling at them things they didn't go
to college together Justin I'm so sorry
mr. president just a nice trip that's
one class looks like Keith Richards with
a glass of warm milk the episode even
opens with Walt insulting his own
birthday gift to Elliott stupid gift the
sentimental wall sinking immediately
he's telegraphing that he feels inferior
to Elliott and his money
this difference in status is evident by
the wardrobe worn by the party yes Jesus
yes we didn't get the baby mmm
they were baby color that symbolizes
normalcy in Breaking Bad Elliott is
wearing beige over a white shirt
symbolizing his purity and goodness the
Walton Skyler are over and gaudy blue
they're wearing what a poor person might
think rich people would wear to a pool
party it's interesting to rewatch this
episode knowing more about Walt's past
and I sold my share to my two partners
care to guess what that company is worth
now 2.16
billion as of last more guy so you can
only imagine what must be going through
his head as he browses through their
library he's standing here he sprained
it looks small on out of place what
looks at a Scientific American cover
story about Elliot echoing this scene
and the pilot as well actor this is a
fantastic analysis already might as well
have been a participation certificate or
an award for a pen so in this episode is
what looks at this magazine cover we now
know he believes that all of this should
be his my hard work my research and you
and Elliot Bing millions on it the party
guests talk about his glory days
extolling him like a legend if I could
count there he was he was just a master
of crystallography but now he couldn't
even admit that he's a mere high school
teacher I
potato toward education ah what
university after one ramen noodles
touches Elliot the to reconnect was the
same guy who always smelled like
chocolate milk it was then the
unexpected happens
Elliot the billionaire a spur walks help
you may be exactly what we need
by doing this Elliot places himself in a
lower status position now Walt has a
glimmer of hope
maybe now his genius will be recognized
he can return from the lab reclaim a
small piece of what should have been his
maybe now it can be his face get his
woman back yeah but then the most
crucial moment the most crucial line and
breaking bad
we have excellent health insurance oh
I'm faded Walt is is he realizes Elliot
didn't actually need his help
he just hit him a moment ago they were
two men making a deal and now Walt is
once again low status Elliot is the real
man who provides for his family Walt as
a loser who needs to beg for help just
to survive rather than faces
insecurities and a mature way Walt
externalizes his feelings some
face-saving bull it and then in a moment
of metaphor shadowing his widow male ego
focuses his rage onto Skyler I don't
like the way you talk about my private
affairs just like many fans of Walter
why did in real life social media
Schuyler going over his head to ask for
help makes him feel like less of a man
like a boy whose mom is helping him try
on pants
she made him feel like he doesn't have a
say in his own life and as we'll see in
the next sequence that's the last thing
that Walt wants in the second sequence
which I call the options it centers on
the intervention Skyler holds from wall
the family's goal is to beg him to
accept treatment not just to accept
Gretchen Elliot's money but to accept
any treatment at all and this is one of
the best intervention scenes in TV
history right up there with the soprano
right my own mother Guillen who uh-oh
first the family appeals to Walt Skyler
is emotional and concise now that
Elliott is more than willing to pitch in
well I know I understand that it's hard
for you to accept help maybe it's the
way you were raised Hank its lost in a
tangent its bottom of the ninth
you're up captain now Huber's remarks
probably cut the deepest your teeth no
father wants his son to question his
courage or call him out for not being a
man returns the scene in the Ted by
introducing another point of view I
think you should do whatever you want to
do and then she sways Hank what maybe
what's a dime like a man
this adds humor to the scene but it also
shows that Walt's decision isn't cut and
dry there is a nobility in choosing how
you want to die then Walt takes command
and carefully lays out his feelings in a
brilliant four minute monologue it boils
down to this what I want what I need
here's a choice and this is also where
he spells out his motivation for the
entire show my tired life it just seems
I never you know had a real say about
any of it and he also tells us his
greatest fear me what some some dead man
seminal artificially alive I'm gonna
tell you who to remember me that's the
worst part
Walt doesn't want to be used by other
people he doesn't want to be a thing he
wants to be alive remember his
confession from the final episode of the
show I did it for me I liked it I was
good at it that brings us to the third
section the choice
what wakes up in bed alone he sees
Skyler isn't there he buries his face in
her pillow smelling her hair
he smells her beauty product and
realizes how much he's going to miss her
and that he wants to be with his family
as long as possible the pile of books at
the bedside catches his eye the baby
books have dropped to the bottom of the
stack in favour of a new book about
treating cancer by eating healthy food
that's when he realizes that no matter
what Skyler won't stop fighting for his
life this quiet moment with household
objects is actually foreshadowed by
Skylar's talking pillow with the
intervention that reads find joy and the
little things so in a roundabout way the
talking pillow spoke to wall Walter is
an analytical man
he always wastes every option carefully
before making a decision in this short
moment he's thinking through every
possible outcome for himself and his
family he realizes that Skyler will
never support his decision
she will resent him for the rest of his
life so will his son they want him to
fight but he won't take money from
Gretchen and Elliott he resents them for
billion an empire - my research can you
and Elliott be millions of it he would
have to forgive them for being
successful if they use that success to
save his life and his pride just can't
let him do that he can't take their
charity because that money rightfully
belongs to him
so FPU there's only one way he can pay
for it by cooking meth and this is the
exact moment he makes the choice at this
point Walt is no longer innocent he's
already killed a man but here's where he
decides that he's okay with the
consequences he decides that no matter
what I will have a choice if I can't
decide and on the survive first the
double meaning of the episode tile gray
matter it's the name of Walton Elliot's
company but it's also the name given to
parts of her neurological system all are
true range from here in the gray matter
between our ears Walt makes a choice
Walt decides what kind of man he wants
to be later in his treatment he's
wrapped in plastic like the artificial
thing he dreaded becoming but he can
live with that now because secretly he's
made a different choice to become a
criminal it to be truly alive the
episode ends with him visiting Jesse
cook the reason this episode is so vital
is the wall was offered now say my name
it turns out that Walt is not actually a
good man he's an evil person hiding
inside a good man's skin pretend for a
second that Walt was never offered this
option that every decision he made
really was to protect his family and not
as ego eventually when Gus threatened
his children he would have done the
rational thing and gone to the police
the Walter White full of pride could
never admit defeat he had to win you one
dude I would he dig deep Underwood for
him to work for Gus he has to become Gus
I'm in the Empire business after this
episode Walt would never again make a
pros and cons list before killing a man
from now on to become a monster and this
exact moment Heisenberg was born god
damn right all right guys what'd you
think about the video let me know in the
comments below really argue against you
dude it's really don't argue against it
done right what I love with that this is
focusing on the birth of Heisenberg it's
not saying like this is when he
completely shifted it's that when he
started to accept the beginnings of this
new identity he could inhabit like that
final point that he was breaking down
paraphrasing here was something about an
evil man was always in there and that
he's living in the shell of a good human
being because that's a different type of
perspective to take with this show the
way how a lot of people have viewed it
was he was a good guy and then bad luck
came his way got diagnosed with cancer
and then through a series of unfortunate
choices he eventually went down this
path and his ego start to grow start to
find purpose yada yada
and I think this video does a great job
of doing specifically Ryan's essay here
is showcasing that the seed of
Heisenberg was already in there before
the show even started before the pilot
it just needed some watering on the
plane did you know in order for it to
fully come out and grow because all that
history is already in grain in the
Walter White character biography and
that's now coming out because of this
life-changing moment with being
diagnosed in this math opportunities I
love how he breaks down that's the case
this is the beginning step because
there's not one episode where Walter
white becomes Heisenberg you can't I
don't think you can say that because
you're watching him descend and
simultaneously arc into the embodiment
of the king of the empire Heisenberg the
one who comes knocking because he
doesn't just switch he doesn't slingshot
effect and crack it's a slow morphing
process for the guy but it was always in
him and I didn't quite pick up on that
element until I rewatched the show the
the second time the whole way through
yeah cuz waltz I think makes a nice
negative image to what Heisenberg is
he's all the recessive qualities he's
all the weaker qualities kind of come to
the forefront and yet I think that's a
really nice way to put that that the
moment in which Heisenberg is born is
simply the moment that Walt decides that
he is going to carve his own way and do
some illegal stuff yeah and I like the
way he broke that down in terms of the
offer the option of the choice it kind
of made me think of just script
structure in the sense that there's some
kind of theme at the beginning and
debate around the theme than an ultimate
decision to embark upon something late
into that and in the long form of a show
you know that happens over maybe the
course of a few episodes or something
like that so at first when he was like
the most significant episode is season 1
episode 5 I was like huh and then pretty
soon I was like oh wow this makes a lot
of sense because yeah it really shows
the convergence of circumstances that
lead to that snap decision of alright
I'm gonna accept this path now and the
beautiful thing is Heisenberg really is
just an amalgam of points of no return
consistently crossed yeah you know but
that's the seed that it all grows out of
yeah and I also really love how Ryan
really broke down visual storytelling
here showcasing that a lot of it is so
good at the visual storytelling that
sometimes you chalk up certain moments
in movies or television to open to
interpretation when you really look at
it especially with this breakdown it's
pretty crisp cut clear what's going on
especially in the sex
of the choice when he wakes up out of
the bed smelling the scent of his wife
he's looking at the books and then going
through that moment where he's sitting
at the edge of the bed and the look that
he's given you just watching the
performance him making the choice right
there no dialogue at all and that's not
open to interpretation it's right there
yeah it's clear and that's just great
like the work of Peter Gould and thence
Gilligan who also do better call Saul
and even with the staircase moment that
framing device of everything is so much
larger and he's this tiny person and he
could have had all this he could have
amounted to all this and the show does
slowly start you know deciphering and
picking apart this storyline and then
follows it all the way through the last
episode which i think is pretty neat and
this episode does do the thing that the
pilot I think also really succeeded in
which is getting you to sympathize for
Walter that way you can kind of get on
board for the coming he as he goes
through this journey as I love how you
got the show Breaking Bad then you got
better call Saul which are two different
journeys you go Breaking Bad as a guy
who was leading a good life style wife
child teacher at school who starts going
down a real evil path and then you got
better call Saul which is Jimmy McGill
who has a history of doing bad things
and it's trying to do the right thing
but it just doesn't pan out for him and
he keeps finding himself drawn to the
bad things in life if you guys haven't
seen better call Saul you really should
it's a it's an amazing amazing show I
really liked it he also even bothered to
dive into the costuming and stuff like
that like when they get to the party I
didn't write fully like their characters
throughout the show that I picked up on
like okay Skyler has these colors
typically or Marie has lots of purples
and stuff but I didn't even realize that
yeah everyone at the party is dressed in
beige which is such a normal color just
beige and white and even that idea that
Elliott he's what the white shirt on the
inside is symbolises you know inner
purity and I do like that you know they
bothered to do that too because while
that's a character that we with Walt
kind of slag off I do appreciate that in
the costuming and those kind of details
even as well there are hints to
everything right and also breaking down
that final line is in terms of
encompassing how many words it was yeah
it serves as a cover seeing the
earth of Walter White it's a Heisenberg
I do think it's a great art because this
is a fifth episode he said because I
remember the first episode of goes wrong
in the camper and then he's kind of in
this like push-pull situation where he
doesn't really know what to do even
though he has the opportunity and he
could succeed in it and Jesse's trying
to pull him in and saying we can do a
great job here we can make a lot of
money so to end it with that line of one
go cook it's either you want to cook as
the forwards or wanna cook as two words
to me I heard it it sounded like one I
cook could be a silent why doesn't
matter I'm sure the column boxes are
filled with people harping on that
moment regardless the context and what
that line is embracing like let's do
this it's just a chilling moment and as
a viewer for this show is up it's weird
it's badass it's cool and in real life
it's really not yeah but yeah Ryan it's
drink rush he does an amazing job and I
really think he'll be like at a million
subs before the end of the year I don't
know if it's just him who does all this
by himself but if you guys haven't
discovered his channel yet please go
over I guarantee you you're gonna love a
lot of what you guys see because I've
watched plenty of his easter-egg videos
on my own time he's always so much fun
to watch and he does other videos than
just that - alright guys well subscribe
your screen crush subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
hey listen this with a TJ otherwise
known as totally jumbled wrote you a
poem buddy don't worry I include your
family too so they don't feel left out
it's always a good day to shout out my
man
TJ heavy procrastination on divulging
information on the meaning of his
abbreviation let's break down the name
like a squamous first name is pronounced
Thomas till death do you part was his
promise petting it was hypothalamus when
he charged in the bedroom like a
rhinoceros his wife rode him like a
noble steed shot it straight up and
planted his little seed now they got a
baby that Thomas never feeds to add a
little clarity the J stands for Jeremy
treats his wife orally while their baby
rests on the TV watching the streets of
Sesame if this poem sounds like my
writing has stumbled that's what happens
when he tried to write a
bap totally jumbled he's got a hot-ass
wife named Alicia once I marry your
daughter our child will call her their
Abuelita
hopes khylin is still smiling give her
my phone number so I can start dialing
once she's five I'm gonna get her high
we'll call that night getting sky high
Alicia says Greg you're too old and
creepy
for God's sakes Skyland still a baby
yeah whatever I don't care